SUBJECT 1: Making love in
our country, specifically,
has to be very much planned.
You have to pick
out a date, you have
a take out those four to
five hours of the night, cook
stories, we're at
your friend's place.
SUBJECT 2: Yeah,
it's a headache.
NARRATOR: This young,
unmarried couple,
from Delhi, India don't want to
appear on camera because they
fear for their safety.
In India kissing in
public or holding
hands can be considered immoral.
And such acts can
even spark violence.
In 2014 members of India's
ruling Hindu Nationalist,
Bharatiya Janata Party set
about to vandalize a cafe all
because a couple was
seen kissing there.
SANCHIT SETHI: I you prefer
living in a society wherein
people are doing what they want
It creates a whole, kind of,
happy ecosystem.
NARRATOR: That
was Sanchit Sethi,
who together with
Blaze Arizanov,
are among the co-founders
of Stay Uncle.
A two and a half year old
startup that helps unmarried
couples in India book
hotel rooms discretely.
The founders felt compelled to
create Stay Uncle after hearing
story after story of
young unmarried couples
trying and failing to conduct
relationships in secret.
BLAZE ARIZANOV: The
courage came when
we saw those almost horror
stories which our couples were
sharing with us.
How they were denied
hotel stays at 2 o'clock.
How girls used to cry on the
reception window [INAUDIBLE].
The receptionists used to ask
them, are you a prostitute?
How they were left
outside to wander
in the middle of the night
on dangerous streets because
of stupid, silly reasons.
We just have to do
something about it.
NARRATOR: The service
set-up is simple.
Couples can log on to
Stay Uncle's website
to find an array of hotels
that will accept them
with no issue,
which is technically
the law for all hotels as
long as the guests are of age.
But most importantly
couples who book
a hotel through the
website are assured
that they will be
safe from attack
at the hotel they
choose to stay in.
SANCHIT SETHI: We
provide the sense
of confidence in these people
that all the hotels we work
with are going to be very safe.
There will be no
questions asked.
And they will be
given a safe stay,
there will be no
police raids, and all.
NARRATOR: However,
Stay Uncle was
difficult to get off
the ground initially.
SANCHIT SETHI: It has been
pretty difficult because what
we're trying to do is something
the industry's not used to,
and the people aren't used to,
not even the customers, not
the suppliers.
NARRATOR: Eventually some hotels
were won over by the idea.
AJIT PANDEY: [SPEKING HINDU]
NARRATOR: The hesitancy
from hotel owners like Ajit
speak to deep seated
conservative ideas around love,
sex, and intimacy, in India.
CHANDRA PRAKASH: [SPEKING HINDU]
NARRATOR: Chandra Prakash is the
president of Akhil Bhara Hindu
Mahasabha, one of the oldest
national political parties
in India.
And though his opinion of
Stay Uncle may seem strong,
they are representative of
conservative values regarding
physical intimacy in India.
CHANDRA PRAKASH:
[SPEAKING HINDU]
NARRATOR: Yet for young
women and men in India
services like Stay
Uncle represent
a gradual, but significant,
cultural shift in attitudes
about dating among
India's youth.
SUBJECT 1: I mean, it's called
making love for a reason,
you need this to grow.
Romance is all about physical
intimacy after a certain level.
Well, you can be all
romantic, but you
have to express it in
cards and gestures.
You know, there's only
so much they can do.
So yeah, the physical
intimacy is very important.
SUBJECT 2: It's very important.
SUBJECT 1: They are providing a
platform with a lot of safety.
That's the biggest
concern for everyone, one,
we are safe, second,
no one gets to know.
and Stay Uncle takes
both of those criterias.
SUBJECT 2: Yeah.
SUBJECT 1: Stay Uncle is a
bold but very good and helpful
initiative.
BLAZE ARIZANOV: It's the culture
and you cannot always classify
culture as good or bad.
It's a very subjective feeling.
We just said, let's do it.
Let's make a breakthrough.
And let's see if this
is a sentiment which
other people share.
Thousands, so far, share
our world view and share
our, sort of,
dream of the way we
would like to see India in
the next few years, coming up.
NARRATOR: If you want to
learn about another group
that that's trying to change
the world around them,
watch this video about
the Salvage Supper Club.
This nonprofit organizes
dumpster dinner parties
that bring awareness to
the problem of food waste.
SPEAKER 3: What we do is host
multi-course dining experiences
where every course is made out
of food that would commonly
go to waste.
It's prepared by chefs who
really know what they're doing
and it's food that people could
make on their own, often times.
NARRATOR: Thanks for
watching Seeker Stories,
be sure to subscribe to
see new videos every week.